these are early days for this trading
platform what are the hurdles as you see
them to the further expansion of it well
the the hurdles are hurdles that we see
because it's a federally illegal product
so because we have to operate on a state
to state basis we really look for
state's infrastructure helped us grow
our business so if you look what we've
built is we've built an ecosystem that
allows industry participants but also
regulatory agencies the ability to truly
track this product also taking cash out
of this system using some of the ACE pay
products and that we built so it's truly
in a in early-stage industry but if you
look at the growth its growing at such a
euphoric pace and what you truly need is
you need infrastructure software to help
this industry grow if you look at the
participants like Dixie elixirs native
roots who the largest in the industry
they have to in a competitive
marketplace lower their costs if you
look at the commodity itself that they
need to produce their products you have
to find a fair and orderly marketplace
to do so and they need that transparency
weed sales may be growing at a euphoric
pace as you put it but there is a
problem here in that trading contracts
are by no means standardized right and
neither is the product how do you
overcome that hurdle and I'm glad you
asked that because what we have today is
we have a we call a a cash marketplace
so it's for the physical product itself
but to get to a derivatives marketplace
the one most important thing is that
settlement price that is delivered in a
cash market so for us the goal is to
start within the physical marketplace
thus being able to deliver a cash
settlement price in the future and
really moving on towards a derivatives
marketplace and if you look at the board
and my team we are were Wall Street guys
we come from the e-commerce space and
the reason that my board is so important
and if we look at Richard Schafer who
was the chairman of the NYMEX
they had the wherewithal in a
face-to-face marketplace to actually
take that exchange and they went
electronic why because they saw the
opportunity in the marketplace the
markets are changing
and as you need efficiency in a
marketplace you need these types of
platforms haven't interviewed some
people in the legalized marijuana
industry what I've heard over and over
again is that they're just regulations
haven't kept up with where things are I
remember talking to folks saying that
banking was a huge x-factor looking to
the DOJ to give them some clarity on
that how do you in your position push
forward or get some of that regulatory
clarity I imagine you need it what we do
and we operate actually if you look at
our business we operate under dodd-frank
and we work within the coal membrane the
whole idea and the concept here is is to
truly deliver a product that can help
scale this industry at a federal level
the banking industry although has the
ability to enter this marketplace it
doesn't and there's certain reasons they
won't what we've done is we've built a
Treasury and cash management system
built into this process now through one
of our strategic partners who is
actually in the Treasury and cash
management business thus giving these
participants the ability now for the
first time to truly become what we call
good corporate citizens allowing them to
transact with wire allowing them to send
ACH allowing them to truly bring
insurance to the industry bring
participants that will provide goods and
services to people that haven't had the
ability to do so
looking years into the future let's say
this exchange has taken off you have the
derivatives contract going are we gonna
see high-frequency trading in weed
futures are we gonna see speculation
what's gonna happen well what I what I
think is most important is if you look
at the marketplaces that are opening up
and I'll use California it's probably
going to be one of the largest market
places in the country currently we're at
about a five billion dollar industry
growing at the fastest pace of any other
industry in the world right now
California alone can can truly actually
triple these numbers what you have to
have is you have to have infrastructure
commoditization of this product is
happening today if you look at what the
nestles of the world needs sugar for
you're finding that if you look at the
numbers in Colorado its
edibles in the consumables market that's
actually outselling the flower two to
one so what you're finding is
commoditization of the flower itself to
produce all of these other goods so you
truly need a fair and orderly
marketplace to do so just like we see in
sugar the fortunate part of what we get
to do is enter a marketplace now before
many participants can and we've brought
a team that can help us extrapolate this
business globally